here with reaction RNC spokesperson
Kelly mackaninee is with us Fox News
correspondent at-large Geraldo Rivera
Florida Attorney General Pam Bondi Pam
we'll start with you got a lot of issues
on the table tonight
where would you want to start very
important issues why think first with
the UN since we're in New York and the
president is that what you're hearing
them tomorrow I'm speaking at the
Concordia summit tomorrow on human
trafficking which of course is huge
Iranian big part of immigration sure is
it sure is absolutely we've been working
with the Mexican government actually and
that's why I'm all for building the wall
to and that the drug crisis and the
African government as well on human
trafficking but you know China's got to
come to the table of course and
President Trump has made that very clear
under his table on North Korea they have
a lot of power over North that's what
I'm talking about Shawn they absolutely
do because they have a tremendous amount
of power over North Korea and that's how
we can stop this madman you know this
maniac front from going forward I
thought of you we are both big freedom
of speech guys I don't call for boycotts
I don't call for for firing people not
even an Isis pose with a severed head of
the president although you even suggest
that it could be a crime as a threat to
the president it seems like the
intolerance in this country now is
almost solely on the left because if any
conservative spoke at the Emmys the way
about Obama the way they speak about
Donald Trump our president you know the
outrage would be loud fast furious and
conservatives probably would end up
fired I was gonna say of the United
Nations show on that it was
dysfunctional and bloated I think the
same thing about the Emmy Awards Show
last night was dysfunctional and bloated
I mean it gets so predictable that
they're gonna hit Trump they're gonna
hit him you know with the the whatever
their acceptance speeches they're gonna
wind it around until finally they can
take a jab at the president ironically I
thought that the pros did the best job I
think Stephen Colbert was funny in the
bit with Sean Spicer you know I think
that it's great when you poke fun at
yourself you know when you can disarm
the audience and I thought that she once
PI sir did a lot of good for himself
he's certainly jacked up his his
speaking fee you can chat up his
speaking but
why do you go right to the business
aspect of that's which cracks me up you
know as I listened a little bit last
night and I couldn't watch it it's
intolerable to me Kayli but there's one
thing that that is of note all of the
lies that are told every two and four
years in elections in this country by
Democrats Republicans are racist sexist
misogynistic homophobic xenophobic
Islamophobic they basically that's what
they believed they believed the
Democratic lie the president is unlike
past presidents he's fighting back
against the lie and I think it's
refreshing because it's it's something
that is so vicious that they've gotten
away with it's now made it to the
mainstream where people believe this
garbage Seana it's so sad you're exactly
right this is straight out of the
PlayBook of the left this demonization
philosophy go back to 1980 go back to
Ronald Reagan they said that Ronald
Reagan raised the specter of white
sheets they said that voting for Ronald
Reagan was like a good German voting in
Hitler's Germany I've on and on and so
on and so forth demonizing him as a
racist as a misogynist the same exact
things they're saying about President
Trump it's false it's defamatory
and president Trump's fighting back and
it kills those liberals it kills the
Hollywood elite that that's why they use
their entire platform to skewer the
president all right let's go to the
agenda Pam Bondi I think the president
you agree with me I think that he's got
to get the funding first I would think
you agree it would be a good thing as
conservatives know we always want to
send things back to the States
absolutely the health care if he gets
his tax plan in place includes things
like getting rid of the alternative
minimum ending the double death tax
which people pay I think an energy
independent I think that Spurs economic
growth we've never seen in since Reagan
of course it does because we have a
businessman who's President of the
United States and that's what the
liberal elite can't handle and they're
not going to get to President Trump he
we know him he's not going to be
affected by it he's going to charge
forward with his agenda to fix our
country and it's got to start with tax
reform we've got to build the wall we've
got to repeal and replace Obamacare my
state of course we were lead counsel on
that so that's very important to us and
the entire country and he's
he's not gonna stop Heraldo for the
first time in a long time after talking
to a lot of the leadership this weekend
in the house and talking to a lot of
rank-and-file in the House and Senate
I'm thinking the items I just mentioned
actually could get done I didn't believe
it up until now well I think you may be
a bit optimistic there show and I think
the one issue you haven't really focused
on this evening I think is the priority
I mean North Korea has the the the
possibility of affecting all of our
lives in the way 9/11 did for the worse
I think that we have John Bolton in the
next segment I did mention it in my
opening in terms of Obama care I don't
know where people are getting the
optimism that this time the GOP is gonna
get there at because you get one vote
away right now I didn't tell you for a
fact that it's gonna be John McCain John
McCain did though is is is John McCain
the the Saint did war hero is he gonna
go this way yes buddy Lindsey Graham
that sponsor in the bill maybe get you
know all these people promises I think
Lisa Murkowski she could hold it up
Susan Collins could hold it up and Rand
Paul don't three people in terms of
domestic policy let them focus on
something that is attainable I think
that we've been spending the last week
or so concentrating heavily on tax
reform right and you laid it out in a
pretty clear fashion three tax rates
instead of seven and so forth and so on
why can't we concentrate why can't we
now after seven and a half years with
this you might you know or Barney
baloney why don't we do something that
we can actually achieve to say you may
be right most people could walk and chew
gum most Americans that have a sense of
urgency that actually works 16 hours a
day and don't take off months at a time
it might be right there so I I hate to
concede a point that they're lazy and
never underestimate their incompetence
but I'll give Kaylee an opportunity to
respond to you well you know Geraldo
talked about healthcare being attainable
or unattainable in his words this is
indispensable to the well-being of the
American people and I want to point out
to your viewers Sean if Graham Cassady
passes look what passed going back to
conservative principles putting the
decision-making in the hands of this
dates not the federal government which I
know AG Bondi fought valiantly for when
she led counsel on this yeah
all right from your lips to God's ears
Pam welcome to New York great to see you
Geraldo my spy my adopted brother thank
you love you brother thank you that he'd
been so nice to me thank you so much
Kayleigh we love having you isn't it
better the worst person you're dealing
with is not Van Jones but her although
he's not that bad he's actually a good
guy and one of my best friends what we